the united kingdom has made history by
becoming the first and only country to
formally leave the
european union the two sides did manage
to come up with a last-minute trade
agreement to prevent a
possibly harmful no deal departure now
though they must learn to live together
geographically
but politically independent prime
minister boris johnson
has promised a golden age for the
british people so on to the point we ask
brexit can the uk really go it alone
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much for joining us here on
the show where my guests are
professor daniel bertsel from berlin's
free university who argues that london
is left with no influence over either
new regulations or the size of financial
contributions
instead of taking back control it's
taxation
without representation also with us is
john worth a british blogger based here
in germany who argues that
as the uk eu trade deal begins to be
understood
there are going to be a lot of unhappy
people on both sides
of the channel and a very warm welcome
too to tom nuttle
berlin bureau chief of the british
economist who says the deal reflects the
british desire
to reduce market access and trade links
in exchange for a greater degree of
sovereignty
in that limited respect he says it can
be considered
a success thank you all through for
being here today interesting statements
there tanya tanya bertsel
uh professor bertzel from the uh free
university here in berlin
uh history has been made britain has
gone
has boris johnson delivered
i would say no boris johnson has not
delivered because he promised that
britain would take back
control and i don't see that britain has
actually taken back control it is still
subject indirectly at least to eu
regulations because
i mean they agreed that there can be
divergence but only as long as fair
competition is guaranteed
and this is decided in the end by any by
the eu uk partnership council so it's
not decided by the british government
secondly britain will continue to pay
into the used budget so
my british money takes players money
still will go to brussels speakers
less than before yes true but still it
does and britain has no control of how
how high these contributions will be so
i think
i mean we can talk about what
sovereignty means but if it means
independent decision making i think
britain will be
very much constrained about by what the
eu will decide in the future
tom what do you make of all that um i i
i half agree um i mean
there well i think the place to start
perhaps because partly because it
animated so many of the
people who back brexit in the first
place is actually on immigration
um one of the elements that the
government always boasted
that it was going to take back control
of was britain's borders now it is true
that there will of course there will no
longer be free movement of eu citizens
to britain and and vice versa
um it's not entirely clear what
immigration regime is for britain is
going to replace
what we had in the past um and from an
economic point of view you might
consider
that britain has shot itself in in the
foot but uh
to put it bluntly when you're a member
of the european union you do not have
control over your borders in the sense
that you are obliged under most
circumstances to
uh to get your borders open to to
citizens from the rest of the club
britain no longer has to do that on the
regulatory side
um that tanya was discussing that's i
mean the proof of the pudding is going
to be in the eating
um we'll have to see how all of these
mechanisms these councils these
uh joint associations work in practice
because everybody to a certain extent is
groping in the dark here these things
have been set up from scratch there
isn't
in most cases there isn't really a model
for them um
what i'm going to be curious to watch is
not so much the extent to which britain
now seeks to diverge from whatever
particular rules it has concerns about
in the single market in most cases i
don't think that britain will want to
diverge from them
and what it seeks to do in the future uh
things like
emerging technologies um where britain
might
some members of this or a future british
government might decide that it would be
in the national interest
not necessarily to follow european
regulations and to go it alone
john you've been nodding vigorously i
agree with that
at the pragmatic level but for me the
big question is is how pragmatic
is the british government in approaching
what comes next
for me this is essentially an
ideological
win or even a political win potentially
for boris johnson but the practical
headaches which are going to come
are going to make this thing turn quite
sour quite quickly for a lot of british
people
whether that's ultimately going to lead
to terms how is it going to turn sour
well
it's going to have a practical impact
for
ev not everyone's lives but for millions
of citizens lives at a very
practical everyday level prices will
increase
we know that there are already um
difficulties and shortages in northern
ireland with the supply of
food to northern irish supermarkets
we've seen
german postage companies refusing to
send packages to the uk at the moment
due to the increasing
bureaucracy there's a bit of coronavirus
in on that one um as well
when british try to go on holiday and
there they face additional complications
um or want to go and visit a holiday
home those those kinds of issues
british small companies that simply say
we can't actually export to the european
union any longer
because the bureaucracy of so doing is
that much more complicated
so those are the very series of
complicated practical difficulties that
britain
and on the european union side if you're
exporting from the eu to the uk as well
are not solved we don't know the answers
to those sorts of practical problems so
far
but politically speaking boris johnson
can say at the supervision level
at least it looks like he's delivered
well boris johnson for his
own part says that uh the the
uh deal that we've just been talking
about has opened a new chapter
in britain's british history allowing
the british people to take control of
their own law
laws and their national dense dens
destiny
let's take a brief look at some of the
changes that will click in over the
coming weeks and
months
vacationing in spain will become even
more complicated for brits who crave the
sun
if they want to stay there longer than
90 days they'll need a visa
british citizens have lost the right to
freedom of movement in europe
moreover eu citizens who live in britain
and want to work there
will now have to prove their value to
the state via a point-based immigration
system
this is bad news for british farmers who
rely on eu workers during harvest
seasons
massive traffic jams on the nation's
borders will become routine
because all goods that come in and go
out of the country
will be checked for customs documents
it's also a blow to fishers in northern
france
they can no longer fish in british
waters from which they've gotten
80 percent of their fish until now
a lot will change for british bankers
and shareholders as well
when where and how much they can work
will be decided in brussels
[Music]
that's a trademark you're not a service
dude
uh you you've got a point that you
really want to make
out with it i'm just saying i think two
things first
i agree that migration is really a point
uh where britain can take back control
although be fair both with regard to
gibraltar and and northern ireland you
know if the
the border between the eu and britain is
not at
at the british border it's actually
within britain and so i mean
but okay granted the point with
migration what about the services you
know i mean this is a trade deal
and for the eu this is important but for
britain the financial service sector is
much more important and nothing was
agreed here so it will depend a lot
on what's going to happen in the future
with regard to a deal a potential deal
between the eu and the uk that needs to
be struck
and probably will tell quite a while tom
reality will
slowly sink in um
i mean i think in terms of the economic
impact of the country clearly
what we have done to put it bluntly is
we have erected barriers to trade that
didn't exist previously
and that means that britain will be
poorer than it otherwise would have been
it's
it's a pretty sort of straightforward
trade-off what's going to be interesting
is to see to what extent
the deal um that was just agreed can
provide some sort of basis for
building up more extensive links in the
future so you were just talking about
financial services
absolutely crucial essential part of the
british economy
um which basically don't feature in the
deal at all
i have no idea how that will play out
but what does seem clear is that if
britain wants
more access into the single market for
its very substantial financial services
industry then it will need to make
concessions and that may look something
like
having ironically a more relaxed
rule on migration for eu workers now
that's clearly not something that's
going to happen any time
soon but over the long term you know i
think
everything is up for grabs and we always
have to remember what happened
um in the years leading up to britain's
original accession into
uh what was then the european community
in the early 70s
it was britain looking at its neighbors
looking at france looking at west
germany and thinking
they seem to be growing richer than us
what's going on there yeah and you've
just said that the uk is going to become
poorer the wasn't part of the the
promise wasn't all about abstract things
like sovereignty and freedom
it was a concrete promise that people
were going to have better lives in the
foreseeable future
yeah i mean well poorer than it would
otherwise be not poorer than it is now
which i think is is an important
distinction to make
um i mean we all know that there that
the campaign
and the the the brexiteers um spun
the british electorate um a few tall
tales in
in the course of the campaign and
beforehand um but i mean
well i i i don't think there's any
simpler way to put it than that if you
put up barriers to trade
especially with what is by far your
largest trading partner
then you are going to be poorer than you
otherwise would have been and sort of
questions about
the contribution to the eu budget and
neither here nor there yes britain was a
net
contributor and will no longer be paying
um sums of that magnitude into the
budget
but uh but its firms will be exporting
less it's uh there will be fewer
customers for its
goods and services therefore there will
be less tax revenue there will be less
going to the treasury so there's you
know that's a pretty straightforward
decision that was made
sovereignty of whatever thought
regulatory borders
whatever legal whatever else in exchange
for
less access to the market of your
biggest trading partner mm-hmm
meanwhile tony european leaders i've
written down what they said about the
trade deal historically important
important milestone major step forward
so
what what impact is this deal going to
have on the european union
brexit is often treated as an instance
of disintegration and it depends how you
define this integration yes we the you
for the first time lost a member right
but at the same time
this isn't in a way and somewhat
paradoxically actually
galvanized integration among the
remaining 27 members in many respects
first
i think um the deal the the the multi
multimedia and your financial framework
plus the new generation
eu the the economic recovery program
that was decided
um i don't think would have been
possible with britain sitting still on
the table
secondly the eu has been the 27 members
that have been
incredibly united in their position when
negotiating with the uk
which was not obvious at the very
beginning particularly germany with its
strong economic interest in britain
we sort of blink seemed to be blinking
merkel was
at the very beginning was sort of
calling for a pragmatic deal
and the polish because of their interest
in you know migrant workers
sending them to britain i mean it could
have well happened that the european
union the 27 would have
unraveled and then it would have been a
different deal so
already in these two respects i think we
see more rather than less europe so
it is a historic deal in many respects
but i think it is in the end the impact
for the you will be
positive rather than negative okay we
mentioned the brexiteers they
argue that the uk has got itself a free
trade deal with no tariffs no quotas
at the same time there's a vision of
what's being called a nimble britain
uh setting its own trade agenda and
forging trade agreements around the
world
let's listen to what boris johnson has
been saying about all of that and then
we'll
speak to john first of all what this
deal gives us
is i would say pretty much the best of
both worlds because you have
a gigantic free trade agreement
but you also have the flexibility that
people wanted and that
we all care about to do things
differently and better
[Music]
john you were swearing and cursing
don't but why were you swearing and
cursing
this notion that britain gets the best
of both worlds is completely wrong
and britain has put up trade barriers
towards its biggest market and if you
look
at at goods and services this is clearly
a deal which is
more solidly in the interest of the
european union than it's in the interest
of the uk
the eu has a trade surplus in goods
towards the uk
the deal is good or relatively good with
in
in goods because there are no tariffs
and there are no quotas the uk
has an export surplus in services to the
eu
and the deal is extremely thin on
services
so this idea that it's some kind of
win-win boris johnson also talks about
how
this is going to be there was something
will be different but it'll be a
reduction in bureaucracy
he said about this deal this is also not
true because british small companies had
basically a market of 28 countries they
could export to which was like their
national market
now they've just got the market of
england wells in scotland not even the
one
market of northern ireland that they can
export to without bureaucratic hurdles
so this this notion that this is uh
somehow a win-win all round
uh that's that's johnson being
economical with the truth and they're
going to make up for
all of what you said with this notion of
a nimble britain
um yeah i mean this might be an
interesting point to bring in
a theme that we haven't touched on yet
which is foreign security policy and i
used to be based in brussels and i
remember at the time soon after the
brexit referendum when we were all sort
of trying to figure out what was going
to happen
how these negotiations were going to
work the general assumption was that
it was going to be a nightmare to
negotiate both the withdrawal agreement
and then
the economic trade deal that would
follow but it was in nobody's interest
nobody wanted any sort of great rupture
on foreign security defense policy and
this was a place uh this was one
area where britain did have some very
substantial cards to play being
a major foreign security player but
actually in the end what happened is
that you have very very little on that
at all and that was at the request
of the british we paid a little bit less
attention to that understandably than we
have to the economic aspects of the deal
but i'm going to be very curious to see
how britain
decides to use what i suppose you could
call freedom that it has procured for
itself
on foreign policy here and one thing to
watch is a so-called e3 grouping britain
france and germany
which was crucial in negotiating the
nuclear deal with iran back in 2015
this is a you talk to diplomats on all
sides and they're all interested in
retaining this grouping and not only
on the iranian file um so this is going
to be one way
should it choose to do so for britain to
retain one foot in as it were the
european foreign policy space
okay but tanya nimble britain i still
want to go back to it because it is
important this is the brave new world
this is the future
well you know we can talk about formal
sovereignty and formal autonomy but we
live
in a world in which states and people
are increasingly
interdependent so the question is how
much you can actually make of your
of your formal sovereignty right in
terms of negotiating new trade deals the
eu
is the largest economic bloc in the
world and it has concluded a whole
number
particularly recently of trade deal with
japan with south korea with important
trading nations britain china exactly
china is
and uh britain will have to do it on its
own and of course its bargaining power
would be much lower
in comparison to the eu when you talk
about bargaining power i try to sort of
imagine what strategy they're going to
adopt and what they're sort of
in corporate terms you would say what is
their u what is britain's unique selling
point
now but that's exactly the point that
britain doesn't have an answer to that
we saw just yesterday boris johnson said
ah i'd like some ideas from british
businesses about
what deregulation we would like to see
but hang on
we've been trying to have this argument
about brexit for four years already like
you're wanting to basically
argue for your rationale after you've
already gone through with the whole
thing now
if britain had a clear idea of
essentially to say
we're going to be a world power in
biotech or a world power in artificial
intelligence or in
data services or whatever it might be
and could focus heavily on that on
or on a few small points but that idea
has not got beyond the id just
essentially largely slogans
from the british government at the
moment so you'd need a plan
and we basically still don't have one
from the british government and if i may
add that little plan they had was
destroyed by the deal because they
dreamt of becoming a kind of a tax haven
right financial services no agreement
and if they believe they can become a
tax haven and
export their financial services to the
eu be my guest
and secondly this whole idea of
deregulating right in order to produce
cheaper and then become more competitive
is gone out of the window by the eu
insisting on a level playing field
there's an interesting domestic
component to that um which i don't think
anybody really saw coming which is that
the
the majority that this government has
this very substantial majority was built
in part
on winning seats so-called red wall
previously held labour seats with a very
different sort of electorate than the
conservative party normally has
these are not voters who want to see
britain turn into a sort of you know
a singapore a low a tax haven a low tax
low regulation sort of space low low
welfare state
so there is potentially a very big
political tension here between
some of the arguments that were made um
from one of the
constituencies of the brexit bloc a few
years ago and then the people who it was
who enabled the conservative party to
have this very substantial majority
and enable them to get rid of all of the
problems that theresa may had to deal
with because she didn't have majority so
that
watching how that tension plays out in
the next few years is going to be one of
the interesting domestic political
aspects of this i think
it sometimes seems that the sort of the
great british people really would like
to live
like the european lifestyle
but on an anglo-saxon tax regime
that doesn't really add up but if you
look at that if you look at the
percentage of british gdp which is
in the hands of the state britain is
actually not at the bottom of that
league table if you compare it to
estonia for example so there's a bit of
that but
but to me this very interesting question
is how how do the british see themselves
or particularly how the english see
themselves i think we should
term it that way which is you need to
have some kind of
national debate and discussion about
where the strengths and weaknesses
are what the limits are of what's been
done but i don't see a country that's
ready to kind of come to terms with what
it's done
at the moment it's a very shrill and
very emotional debate going on in the uk
and a government that's happy to keep on
having that sort of shrill and emotional
debate
um you need to have some some more
fundamental political and
economic questions boris johnson
despite all that you've just said boris
johnson says it won't be a bad thing for
the eu to have a prosperous dynamic
contented
uk on its doorstep the uk is going to be
sort of
you know prompting and prodding the eu
to
break with uh abbott's habits of old
maybe but the difficulty is is that
boris johnson had
few friends in the eu and britain's
trust or level of trust in the eu was
very low
through through the process of
negotiating this brexit deal this
particularly the commitment in the
so-called internal market deal to
breaking
in international law and breaking a
commitment already made
so britain can only achieve that through
practical action i.e what british
companies what british citizens do and
how they behave
if britain can make a success out of
brexit that will pose a challenge to the
european union but at the moment it
doesn't look to me
particularly politically whether britain
is capable of turning brexit into a
success because the british government
is that incapable of setting a direction
let alone actually implementing what it
says it seeks to achieve
fun sounds a bit like you want that the
eu
doesn't want brexit to be a success i
would be a little bit careful because i
agree i mean it would be beneficial for
both sides
if britain came out of brexit you know
strong
because we need britain britain was an
extremely good member
i mean despite all the the the rhetoric
britain was a a sort of an exemplary
member state in many respects
it has the highest compliance with the
eu law and it has
played a very constructive role in in
the common foreign security policy but
also other policy areas so we do have an
interest in britain prospering and
cooperating with the european union i
just want to underline that
i think it's a couple of sort of coders
to that
um i mean we've been focusing on as it
were the economic example that britain
might
present uh the european union in the
years to come to the extent that there's
divergence and that is going to be
crucial
and it could pose a challenge in some
respects to some parts of the european
union but then there's a political
example
and i think there's two things that i
would mention one is
that um you were touching on this um
earlier
um at the at the moment of brexit and we
should remember of course that donald
trump
was elected u.s president a few months
afterwards there was this
feeling of absolute terror in brussels
and i think in some other capitals as
well as
is this whole thing this whole system
that we've constructed is it on the
verge of collapse so we're looking ahead
at the time to
the coming french presidential election
and one thing we learned i think through
this whole brexit process and and
how awkward and clumsy it was is that
britain has become a very good example
for why you shouldn't leave the eu it's
very very damaging the second thing
which
we'll need to watch in well in the
months ahead really
is whether this country that we've been
calling the united kingdom
can actually survive as a united kingdom
we have elections in scotland
in a few months time we have what is
beginning to look like a pretty
solid substantial uh substantial ish
majority in favor of independence in
scotland
now the the the british government boris
johnson's government says that they will
not get a referendum so we may be headed
towards some sort of
political crisis between london and
edinburgh there um
and that but then of course we have the
the issue of northern ireland as well
um i think the one thing we can say that
is that the stability um
of the united kingdom as a political
unit is looks a lot
less safe than it did in the past we are
gathered here today to talk about the
question
uh can the uk really successfully go it
alone
just very briefly could scotland
successfully go it alone could scotland
prosper on its own because it's a big
it's a relevant question isn't it yeah i
think one of the ironies about brexit in
a way is it
on the one hand it gave the independence
movement a wonderful new argument
we've been tugged out of the eu against
our will the circumstances have changed
we deserve another referendum
on the other hand the fact of brexit
creates a massive new headache
for the smp and the separatists in that
if scotland were to uh to secede from
britain and then to rejoin the eu then
all of a sudden you have another border
problem to deal with just like we had to
deal with with uh
northern ireland and ireland what are
going to be the rules governing
movement of people of goods and services
across that border
that wasn't an issue if uh if england
and scotland were both inside the eu
it would become an issue and that would
be a very hard question for the
separatists to have to answer in another
independence
that would presuppose that scott an
independent scotland would become a
member of the european union i
don't i don't think that's a that's
going to happen this is the heart of
their proposition
yeah but but that the you have to be
making self honest and
and admit that there is it takes one
member state to vote against and you can
be sure that will be spain so forget
about an independent scotland in the eu
so i don't see it so negatively because
it would be an incredible geopolitical
win that's
for the eu to for britain the country
that left
to have split and to take a big part of
it back in
that would be presented as a victory and
i think even spain could be persuaded
great guests great discussion thank you
very much i so wish we could continue
we've got so much more to say but
uh i hope you enjoyed it and if you did
then uh come back next time around
bye-bye cheers
[Music]
[Music]
so
you